Prince Harry's wife Megan had her first
royal engagement on her own this morning
in Fiji look how good they look together
but her visit to a local market was
suddenly cut short because officials had
what they called crowd control concerns
now some royal watchers are wondering if
Megan's busy schedule is catching up
with her
Jonathan Vigliotti is traveling with the
Royals in Suva that's Fiji's capital
Jonathan good morning and good morning
marrying into the royal family can be
hard work even when that work takes you
to a tropical island like Fiji while
Megan's first speech of this tour was
well received at times all of the
attention surrounding her today proved
to be overwhelming the traditional
sounds of Fiji and tears of the crowd
have greeted the royal couple across the
island nation as they arrive at the
University of the South Pacific Prince
Harry and Megan were also given
traditional Fijian leis adorned with
flowers which they would continue to
wear throughout the day wanaka megan
then gave her first speech on the tour
using her global platform to focus on
education
everyone should be afforded the
opportunity to receive education that
they want but more importantly the
education that they have the right to
receive she told the crowd of her own
grit and determination it was through
scholarships financial aid programs and
work-study or my earnings from a job on
campus went directly towards my tuition
that I was able to attend University the
American royal announced two grants
aimed at empowering young women the
younger of which showed up in tiaras
this is probably the closest that we've
been allowed to get to this royal couple
the entire time on this tour look at
these kids so excited to see them right
but Megan's day wasn't without a hiccup
a planned visit to a market was abruptly
cut short world correspondent laraine
eco was one of the journalists with
Megan at the time what happened I think
she felt a little bit hot and flustered
by you know the crowds there the demands
of this tour have taken a little bit of
a toll on her I think for Megan this
being her first major overseas tour she
may have been cooled slightly spiced
prized by how yeah how demanding each
engagement is how you have to put on a
bit of a game face for each engagement
but that is the whole that's the whole
part and possible what comes with being
them the royal family you've got to put
your game face on and Kensington Palace
his official line is that security was
concerned over the size of this crowd
though we do know exhaustion has played
a role on this tour Megan is three
months pregnant
earlier this week she took some time off
before rejoining the tour yesterday
Gayle
Thank You Jonathan she's always got her
game face on and people are so glad to
see her and doesn't she look good she
sounds like she oh she sounds good she
looks good speaking Fiji yeah I like
that